ana júlia só eu tenho 10 anos e hoje vou
falar sobre um assunto muito importante
que é mundo sem fronteiras
o que seria de um mundo perfeito veja
aqui já o irão diz nessa música quem
tudo a ver com esse tema imagine todas
as pessoas vivendo a vida em casa o
herdade de homens
partilhando todo mundo você pode dizer
que são um sonhador nem no inferno
abaixo de nós acima de nós
só o céu e imagine que não houvesse
nenhum país nenhum motivo para matar ou
morrer e nem religião também mas eu não
sou o único espero que vocês juntos há
mais de um ano
para isso está na realidade precisamos
que as pessoas se conscientizem os
problemas que estão atrapalhando a
humanidade
vou mostrar alguns exemplos que está
acontecendo atualmente acolhe uma pessoa
não define seu caráter brancos negros
pardos
todos são iguais e se chama preconceito
racial ou seja quando uma pessoa
discrimina outra pela sua cor terrorismo
à intolerância religiosa atrás de terror
as idades e fortalece o medo ea
separação dos povos como as torres
gêmeas de nova york que foram destruídas
pelos terroristas
famílias inteiras estão fugindo da
guerra da síria este está encontrando as
fronteiras fechadas em alguns países da
europa
isso se chama guerras migração
vamos buscar soluções ampliando os
programas de ajuda às populações menos
desenvolvidas
existem tantas opções religiosas de cada
um e colocar nem tática os direitos
universais a crianças
toda criança tem o direito de educação
respeito e amor e d e e e felicidade
enfim imaginar o mundo sem fronteiras
onde todos são irmãos que podem viver de
forma pacífica em harmonia como podemos
fazer para participar
a paz no dia a dia bem quando é defender
as pessoas que sofrem bullying
intercâmbio cultural ajudar os alunos de
fora sem informar e procurar entender os
costumes das pessoas de outros países e
discriminação racial não se importar com
uma corda pessoa mas sim com que ela tem
por dentro e ajudar os idosos e pessoas
com deficiência ou seja praticar a paz
seja em casa com os familiares seja nas
ruas com as pessoas ou seja nas escolas
com os funcionários professores e
colegas
muito obrigado espero que vocês façam
sua parte porque eu vou fazer a minha